after days of violent protests by
striking taxi drivers South African
police in the township of kayamundi in
Stellenbosch are battling what they say
are looters
they disperse dozens of people trying to
break into a liquor store and break up
other groups with stun grenades rubber
bullets and tear gas
Mini Bus taxi drivers went on strike
nearly a week ago they say they're being
unfairly targeted by authorities who
have confiscated their vehicles for
traffic offenses
and that the law is being abused the
impoundment usually does not take the
vehicle off the road for a protracted
period but what it does do is it compels
the owners of these vehicles to confront
the conduct of the drivers that they
employ and that really is the Crux here
that we have found a mechanism that is
starting to compel Behavior change the
issue of the practice of issuing fines
in terms of the criminal justice system
is not doing that during the strike at
least 10 public buses which people use
as an alternative to minibus taxis have
been torched drivers have also blocked
major highways and Roads and at least
five people have been killed Cape Town
City officials blame the taxi drivers we
distance ourselves from what is
happening out there
the criminal activities that are taking
place we are not part of
we have issued the statement we
discouraged our members when we took the
decision to embark on this area we spoke
to our members and said we don't want to
see any member involving him or herself
in criminal activities hence we are
saying that those are not our members
negotiations to end the strike have
stalled City bosses say they won't
continue talks as long as there's
violence meanwhile tens of thousands of
commuters remain stranded and some
businesses shut while the taxi industry
loses the equivalent of eight hundred
thousand dollars each day the strike
continues
in a country with underlying issues of
poverty and inequality any unrest often
leads to situations like this where
police find themselves having to stop
looting and other crimes officers are
likely to remain on high alert family Al
Jazeera outside Cape Town
foreign